[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un resumen de las noticias
más destacadas relacionadas con la
pandemia de kobe 19 6 santiago lópez
gonzález a continuación algunos de los
temas que vamos a tener en el programa
de hoy
el estado de la florida en eeuu solo
rompió récords de hospitalizaciones las
autoridades locales han impuesto pocas
restricciones pero la variante delta
deja miles de nuevos contagios y
fallecidos entre quienes no se han
vacunado también daremos un vistazo a
las recientes restricciones impuestas en
el estado de texas y también a nivel
federal desde la ciudad de washington
conoceremos también los testimonios de
varios ciudadanos franceses en américa
latina que no han sido vacunados o que
han sido inoculados con vacunas de china
o de rusia que no son avaladas con las
autoridades del país galo por esto
muchos franceses no han podido regresar
a sus países de origen oa su país de
origen en este caso francia también
daremos un vistazo a la situación en
argentina país que con motivo del fin de
las vacaciones de invierno comenzó a
vacunar a los menores de edad que genera
todo tipo de debate entre los padres
también le daremos un vistazo a la
controversia que hay allí por la falta
de segundas dosis de la vacuna sputnik y
finalmente hablaremos de ecuador país
que ya vacuno a más del 50 por ciento
con al menos una dosis de algunas de las
vacunas que están disponibles también
allí están haciendo esfuerzos para
reactivar la industria turística como
motor de la economía ecuatoriana pues
vamos a dar inicio al programa con la
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo asesor
científico de france24 doctor pérez
bienvenido gracias por acompañarnos hoy
en el programa como siempre un gusto
poder hablar con ustedes estos temas que
nos conciernen en torno a la pandemia de
kobe 19 hablemos de los avances que hay
en torno a la variante delta y a la
variante delta plus nuevamente este
delta plus a muchas personas le empieza
a dar un poco de susto porque no saben
exactamente a qué se están enfrentando y
qué diferencias hay con la variante
delta de la que hemos estado hablando a
lo largo de las últimas semanas y que
cada vez hace más presencia en más
países
santiago recordemos que la variante
delta es una variante que lo que aumentó
fue su capacidad de transmisión
la variante delta plus es una variante
que modifica 12
digamos principios de la proteína de
espiga dos cambios 800 que también
aumenta un poco la probabilidad de que
enferme más de la variante sabemos dos
cosas importantes son la variante
natural infectada a una persona a dos y
con la variante delta una persona
infecta entre cinco y ocho personas lo
segundo que sabemos es que las personas
así estén vacunadas pueden portar en
bilis es decir que la vacuna previene de
enfermedad pero no la transmisión en
esta variante y por eso la necesidad de
usar el tapabocas y las medidas que
hemos aprendido durante la parte no está
de más recordar todas estas
instrucciones doctor ya lo mencionaba yo
en el sumario del programa argentina dio
inicio a la vacunación de adolescentes a
personas mayores de 12 años y esto
genera todo tipo de preguntas entre los
padres
y los organismos de las personas
adolescentes están listas para recibir
una dosis de una vacuna que es muy
fuerte que incluso genera efectos
secundarios muy fuertes en algunos
adultos temen que sus hijos tengan que
padecer o enfrentarse a este tipo de
efectos secundarios también otra
pregunta que surge en torno a este tema
porque solamente fueron aprobadas para
los adolescentes o personas menores de
edad las vacunas que son de aire en el
mensajero
digamos contestando esa pregunta y lo
primero las vacunas pues después que se
hicieron en ese grupo de edad de 12 a 16
años hay estudios y los hicieron primero
las vacunas rn a en el momento están
estudios en curso con las diferentes
plataformas ya hay una prueba en el
china por ejemplo para la vacuna de
sinovac y acrítica en curso en europa
hay estudios que están haciendo para esa
población joven con otras plataformas
pero hay que perder el tema a las
vacunas si un niño de 2 meses recibe 6
vacunas en una sola inyección y
realmente es los síntomas son mínimos en
los niños en los adolescentes obviamente
se pueden producir reacciones pero no
van a producir daño en la salud aquí es
importante tener en cuenta que las
vacunas no producen daño a la salud
producen reacciones y esa reacción
inicial se deriva de la que el despertar
del sistema inmune para poder controlar
la infección pero no deterioran la salud
de la persona y la experiencia que se ha
tenido en la israel y en eeuu en
vacunación mayores de 12 años es
bastante prometedora
hay que tener la tranquilidad de que se
pueden vacunar los niños y adolescentes
tienen futuros gana pues vacunar niños
de menor edad doctor pregunta adicional
relacionada con este tema de la vacuna
en adolescentes estamos viendo que
países como alemania como israel ya
están inoculando una tercera dosis o
dosis de refuerzo en las personas
mayores o personas que tienen algún tipo
de enfermedad preexistente que podría
complicarles si llegan a contagiarse con
el cubil 19 estaríamos ante un posible o
futuro escenario de adolescentes también
recibiendo una tercera dosis de refuerzo
de una de las vacunas disponibles
en este momento y una incertidumbre
acerca de esa tercera vez es en este
grupo de población de las personas ya
memorias inmunocompetentes los jóvenes
comorbilidades cada vez hay mayor
evidencia de que un refuerzo
probablemente después de seis meses en
personas mayores y en personas que están
recibiendo activamente medicamentos para
monos suprimirlos o que tienen una
enfermedad que afecta a las defensas
requieren una tercera dosis como pasará
con las otras personas que no tenemos
esa condición es como las preguntas que
hay y que tenemos que hacer es probable
que con el ingreso en las nuevas
variantes todos tengamos que vacunarnos
seis meses un año un año y medio después
con las vacunas que se llaman de segunda
generación para variar pero en el
momento tenemos que concentrarnos en que
la mayoría de las personas reciban la
pauta completa niños adolescentes
adultos mujeres embarazadas personas con
suprimidas porque si no complementamos
la pauta completa de nada va a servir la
tercera dosis
doctor me salgo un poco del tema médico
y científico y paso un tema un poco más
controvertido a nivel político que tiene
que ver con esa moratoria que pidió la o
ms que le pidió a los países que están
más avanzados en la vacunación que se
esperen un poco en cuanto a esta tercera
dosis que quieren ya empezar a inocular
para que los países que están atrasados
o que todavía no han podido ni siquiera
comenzar sus planes de vacunación puedan
empezar a inocular a sus habitantes para
poder equilibrar un poco las cargas el
80 por ciento de las vacunas que se han
aplicado o suministrado alrededor del
mundo han ido a países de altos ingresos
o ingresos medios esto sigue dejando
como lo digo la balanza desnivelada esto
nos va a evitar entonces llegar a esa
anhelada inmunidad del rebaño áfrica por
ejemplo es el escenario más claro sigue
siendo un foco de coronavirus porque
precisamente hay a los países no están
vacunando todavía
sí yo creo que nosotros hemos visto
claramente la inequidad y la vacunación
más para el que más la necesita sino
para el que mayor poder adquisitivo
tiene hablando de países e incluso
hablando de grupos poblacionales es
importante entender que la inmunidad
colectiva con estas nuevas variantes no
será incluso el 70 por ciento en número
sino será mucho más tal vez 85% 90% de
las personas que se vacunen y tenemos
que entender que aquí no es el 70 80 por
ciento de una ciudad de un país ni
siquiera un continente es del mundo para
lograr salir de la fase de pandemia la
fase de pandemia no ataca a países
ciudades o estados ataca el mundo y por
eso tenemos que promover para la equidad
de la vacuna antes de pensar en una
tercera dosis hay que completar las
dosis que hay para la gente que no tiene
y la accesibilidad de las vacunas ha
demostrado que la inequidad en la
proceso de vacunación en una enfermedad
que nos afecta a todos pues es muy
marcada y por eso el llamado a la
sensatez y que nos vacunemos todos y
significa todos
sino el mundo para poder lograr la
inmunidad colectiva doctor yo
lamentablemente buena parte de la
comunidad internacional rechazó este
llamado de la oms y dijeron que van a
continuar con sus planes de hacer una
tercera dosis o dosis de refuerzo doctor
pérez gracias por estos minutos gracias
por aclarar nuestras dudas y como
siempre puede resolver nos estás
preguntas en términos muy simples todo
lo entendemos muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros vamos a hablar ahora
de eeuu a este país está sumido en una
nueva crisis de coronavirus con máximos
registrados hace ya seis meses el
repunte de los contagios según las
autoridades está relacionado
precisamente con la variante delta mucho
más contagiosa como lo decíamos que las
anteriores que hemos evidenciado pero
además también en aquellos estados donde
las campañas de vacunación no han tenido
una gran acogida se están empezando a
notar altos niveles de contagio veamos
eeuu se enfrenta a un fuerte incremento
de contagios de kobe 19 con más de
100.000 contagios diarios el país ha
llegado al máximo visto hace seis meses
el motivo la virulenta variante delta y
el estancamiento de las vacunaciones
entre los más afectados se encuentran
los estados del sur una combinación de
donde tienen una gran cantidad de la
variante delta y una baja cobertura de
vacunación en donde tengamos una
vacunación baja veremos un aumento
pronunciado y desafortunadamente las
escuelas van a ser un acelerador porque
muchos más niños y personal no vacunado
también se contagiarán repunte está
afectando especialmente a los estados
sureños donde las tasas de inoculación
son más bajas
florida epicentro del repunte ya cuenta
con más de 12 mil hospitalizaciones por
kobe 19 y anthony fauci el principal
experto en enfermedades infecciosas del
país afirmó que los casos podrían llegar
a los 200.000 diarios en las próximas
semanas sin embargo con la reapertura la
mayoría de los estados han dejado en
manos de las escuelas locales la
decisión de exigir mascarillas
me siento realmente molesta por no haber
tenido una opción segura me siento
realmente disgustada de que a pesar de
que el gobierno del condado de gente
haya establecido el mandato de las
mascarillas para sus edificios públicos
los niños queden fuera de todas estas
medidas de seguridad en la última semana
eeuu reportó un aumento del 48% de los
positivos respecto al anterior ante el
incremento derivado de la variante de
alta la casa blanca planea ofrecer
inyecciones de refuerzo a la población
más vulnerable
[Música]
el estado de florida en la unión
americana es en este momento el foco de
la pandemia este estado ya rompió todos
los récords de hospitalizaciones vamos a
conocer algunos de los datos que tenemos
allí antes de darle paso a nuestro
corresponsal florida registra ya 2.6
millones de casos confirmados más de 39
mil personas han perdido la vida sólo
allí en el sur de eeuu allí han sido
inoculadas más de 22 millones 800 mil
dosis de vacunas contra el cobista 19
y vamos a profundizar en el caso del
estado de florida con alto nivel si
nuestro corresponsales de france 24 allí
en el sur de la unión americana hola
antonio y comencemos entonces hablando
por el repunte de los casos allí en
florida este récord de hospitalizaciones
que cifras oficiales y qué medidas hay
por parte de las autoridades
hola santi y pues si la situación en
florida cada vez es más preocupante se
han superado récords de contagios y de
hospitalización es algo que no se había
registrado ni siquiera hace un año
cuando este estado también se había
convertido en el epicentro de la
pandemia ahora más de 12.000 pacientes
están ingresados en los hospitales de
florida con más de 2500 camas ocupadas
en unidades de cuidados intensivos de
media la ocupación en los hospitales
está rondando el 89 por ciento así que
los expertos sanitarios avisan que si la
tendencia continúa al alza el sistema
hospitalario podría llegar incluso a
colapsar básicamente porque no podría
aguantar el estrés al que se está
sometiendo por su parte al gobernador de
florida el republicano ron de santis
continúa defendiendo la 'barra libre'
que no hace falta implementar ninguna
medida de restricción contra el
coronavirus que cada uno tiene que hacer
lo que crea conveniente ha dicho que no
van a haber cierres de escuelas tampoco
se va a obligar a nadie a usar
mascarilla y recordemos además que firmó
una orden diciendo que ningún negocio
podría denegar
a alguien por no estar vacunado sin
embargo el sistema de salud jackson el
más grande de florida ha desafiado al
gobernador y ahora requiere que todos
los trabajadores y proveedores estén
vacunados antonio el estado de texas
también vive una situación similar hay
un repunto de los casos si el gobernador
ha ordenado medidas que han sido muy
controversiales han sido muy criticadas
y señaladas como por ejemplo esa ley que
le permite a la policía local detener a
todas las personas que ellos consideren
que tienen aspecto de latinoamérica no
de una persona latinoamericana para
hacerle pruebas para descartar que esté
contagiado de kobe 19 porque creen que
los latinos están dispersando
esparciendo mejor el virus en el estado
si en tejas la pandemia también está
completamente descontrolada y las
autoridades avisan que los casos
positivos están aumentando a un ritmo
muy preocupante también por el
crecimiento de las hospitalizaciones
durante el último mes que han dado un
salto de 292 por ciento en los últimos
30 días los funcionarios sanitarios
admiten que se habían relajado las
medidas al pensar que lo peor de la
crisis sanitaria ya había pasado pero
esta tercera ola de contagios está
descolocando a muchos están viendo un
90% más de casos respecto a la semana
anterior se atribuye a la aparición de
la variante delta mucho más contagiosa y
también porque poco más de la mitad de
la población está completamente vacunada
con más y más personas hospitalizadas el
estado de la estrella solitaria está
registrando una falta de personal en los
centros de salud por su parte el
gobernador republicano de texas greg
abbott ha recibido muchas críticas tras
ordenar a la policía estatal que detenga
los vehículos con migrantes
latinoamericanos con riesgo de kobe 19
ante antonio vámonos hasta el norte del
país al estado de nueva york así hay
nuevas
que han impuesto allí las autoridades de
que se trata en qué consisten
si el alcalde de nueva york el demócrata
bill de blasio anunció que a partir del
16 de agosto se exigirá el certificado
de vacunación para acceder a
restaurantes salas de espectáculos y
también gimnasios con esta decisión la
ciudad se ha convertido en una de las
primeras grandes metrópolis de eeuu en
impulsar algo parecido a lo que sería
una especie de pasaporte sanitario de
blasio también ha dicho que los 400.000
empleados públicos deberán estar
vacunados o tendrán que someterse a test
periódicos de coronavirus esa ciudad de
8 millones de personas y que fue una de
las más afectadas en la primera etapa de
la pandemia más del 70% de los adultos
ha recibido por lo menos una dosis pero
al igual que ha pasado en el resto del
país las vacunaciones se han estancado
por lo que las autoridades están
promoviendo medidas para incentivar las
dosis entre la población
hablemos ahora de medidas a nivel
federal esa posibilidad de que
washington imponga como restricción que
las personas que vayan a visitar eeuu
tengan que estar ya con el esquema de
vacunación completo
joe biden está considerando implementar
medidas mucho más restrictivas sobre
todo con ese objetivo el de impulsar la
vacunación contra la cob y 19 algunos
medios estadounidenses como el
'washington post' afirman que la
administración norteamericana estaría
valorando el uso de poderes regulatorios
o federales como por ejemplo la
congelación de fondos para aumentar esas
tasas de inoculación una medida que por
el momento no ha sido confirmada por la
casa blanca que tampoco ha dicho si
finalmente va a exigir a los extranjeros
que quieran ingresar al país que también
deban estar vacunados pero eso es algo
que también se estaría estudiando por el
momento bailén ha exigido que todos los
empleados federales demuestren que están
vacunados o si no al igual que en nueva
york' deberán someterse a pruebas
periódicas de coronavirus además de
también llevar mascarilla respetar la
distancia social y otras medidas que se
incluyen en ese en ese paquete de
medidas contra el coronavirus antonio
pues tal parece que entonces el plan de
vacaciones y vacunas podría terminar en
eeuu posiblemente si lo prueban muchas
este reporte desde la ciudad de miami y
miles de ciudadanos franceses en
residentes en el exterior muchos de
ellos en américa latina no pueden
regresar a su país de origen algunos de
ellos han sido vacunados en su país de
residencia con algunas de las vacunas
hechas en rusia como el spotlight gay o
con las vacunas chinas
sinovac y scinopharm ninguna de ellas es
avalada por las autoridades de salud de
francia motivo por el cual no pueden
ingresar a su país de origen la ema que
es la autoridad médica de la unión
europea permite para este grupo de los
27 países más islandia noruega y
liechtenstein
las vacunas desarrolladas por facer by
ante johnson y johnson modernas y
astrazéneca de esta última excluye la
vacuna hecha por astrazéneca en los
laboratorios de india
y conversamos con varios ciudadanos
franceses residentes en diferentes
países de américa latina nos explicaron
cuál es la situación que tienen después
de haber recibido alguna de estas
vacunas rusa o china
y compartieron con nosotros sus
opiniones sobre las medidas que tiene el
gobierno francés para mitigar el impacto
de la pandemia que los deja a ellos por
fuera como invitaron para ir a france de
septiembre
y bueno para ir a francia y moverme allá
bien necesito el pas sanitario para
tener el pas sanitario necesita una
vacuna homologada por francia y el que
me completo no el problema es que de las
vacunas que se dan acá aunque son
sputnik scinopharm y astrazéneca
solamente hasta el séneca está
homologada por francia entonces en una
situación un poco gris porque todavía no
me pude vacunar no me quiero vacunar con
una vacuna que no esté homologada por mi
país porque quiero ir allá entonces
ahora estoy intentando rastrear la
vacuna está ascética mediante una página
del gobierno de la ciudad y estoy perdió
un tiempo no ósea porque no la están
dando porque dan mucho si no pagar y la
verdad que no sé si voy a poder ir a mi
país en septiembre yo lo veo más bien
como un posicionamiento estratégico no
francia núñez en europea eligieron sus
socios y descartaron otros
de la misma manera que el gobierno
argentino bueno eligió también sus dos
socios lo veo de forma así política más
que otra cosa y vuela y charlas en el
parlamento francés para ver si se pueden
avalar más vacunas más pues no tengo
intención de viajar cuánto habrá
anunciado pero tengo familia ya no nunca
sabe cuándo va a tener que viajar como
con urgencia y el problema es que el
gobierno francés no reconoce ni la rusa
ni la china y sin embargo tampoco estás
alternativas
me da mucho que pensar en los intereses
económicos y políticos que pueda tener
que puedan tener los diferentes países
de la unión europea porque como por
casualidad la que en las que nos
reconocen es precisamente la rusa y la
china
aparte encuentro esto un poquito
discriminatorio en el sentido de que
pues al venir a colombia
como bien saben tenemos que ponernos y
ponernos diferentes vacunas entre ellas
la fiebre amarilla a mí me tocó una zona
de selva entonces la rabia y todo eso en
ningún momento ha habido problemas de
reconocimiento de esas vacunas que le
acabo de mencionar por una marca o bota
entonces porque por ahora del pueblo na
virus para la vacuna del juegan a virus
hay tantos problemas y como avanzó la
pandemia de kobe 19 a lo largo de la
semana tenemos un vistazo a los números
a nivel mundial ya superamos los 200
millones de casos esta es una cifra
preocupante los fallecidos ya superan
los 4.2 millones de personas mientras
que el número de las dosis aplicadas a
nivel mundial ya superó los 4 mil 341
millones de dosis el 80 por ciento de
estas dosis están concentradas en países
de altos ingresos o medios hay muchos
países que todavía no han podido ni
siquiera inocular una primera dosis
muy bien y ahora demos un vistazo al
extremo sur del continente vamos hasta
argentina y hubo varias novedades a lo
largo de la semana vamos a conocer los
detalles con natalio con soy nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires en natalio
comencemos por el avance de la variante
delta en ese país suramericano
rápidamente se está extendiendo y por
eso están apuntando a vacunar
rápidamente a los ciudadanos
si en argentina por ahora la mayoría de
los casos siguen siendo de la variante
gamma que la cepa conocida como manaos
seguida por la lambda que es la conocida
como andina pero hay mucha preocupación
por el avance de la cepa delta y en
argentina- registrados alrededor de 90
casos de personas con esta variante y
para tratar de retrasar el ingreso de la
variante delta se han impuesto límites
al ingreso de pasajeros desde el
exterior en el momento en este momento
son 1.000 pasajeros por vía aérea
diariamente que pueden ingresar al país
es una situación que ha generado
protestas de parte de quienes se
encuentran en el extranjero y no ven la
posibilidad de ingresar cuando ellos
quieren de regreso al país en ese
contexto el gobierno va a utilizar
autorizó a partir de este sábado del
ingreso de extranjeros que sean
familiares de argentinos o de residentes
en argentinas para tratar de facilitar
el movimiento de algunas de las personas
que necesitan volver o llegar a la
argentina
natalio también esta semana después de
las vacaciones de invierno el gobierno
autorizó la vacunación para los
adolescentes o personas a partir de los
12 años en adelante que más dijeron las
autoridades sobre estos detalles
pero justamente esta semana que pasó
comenzó en argentina la vacunación de
adolescentes de 12 a 17 años con
condiciones priorizadas como diabetes
obesidad
enfermedad cardiovascular crónica o
desnutrición grave que son algunas de
las varias condiciones priorizadas que
informaron las autoridades estos estos
chicos estos adolescentes están siendo
vacunados con la vacuna de moderna que
es de las que están indicadas en el país
en argentina para este grupo de edad y
era un reclamo también fuerte de la
sociedad que se empezará a inmunizar a
los más pequeños por ahora adolescentes
sobre todo en el caso de niños y
adolescentes que tienen algún tipo de
comorbilidad o que tienen algún tipo de
dificultades específicas y que se ven
beneficiados especialmente por la
posibilidad de acceder a una vacuna
natalidad hay en argentina vida
preocupación por las personas que habían
recibido ya dosis de la vacuna sputnik
de esa segunda dosis no llegó por
retrasos por parte de rusia para
suministrarlas ya sabemos de esta
controversia
qué van a hacer entonces con estos
ciudadanos que esperan la segunda dosis
que dicen las autoridades argentinas
si la falta de segunda dosis de sputnik
ven en argentina ha sido un tema de
muchísima preocupación es una vacuna que
ha tenido mucha penetración en el país
la primera en haber llegado al país
especialmente en el contexto de un
posible crecimiento de casos de variante
del está en argentina porque porque
muchas de las personas que tienen
primera dosis de sputnik vez son
personas mayores las primeras en haber
recibido dosis y al mismo tiempo las que
tienen mayor riesgo frente a esta nueva
variante frente a cualquiera de las
variantes pero también frente a la
variante delta por eso tanta
preocupación por que se complete en los
esquemas de vacunación de sputnik ve ya
hay noticias optimistas en este sentido
por un lado el laboratorio de gamma ley
a los fabricantes en rusia informaron
que están normalizando finalmente la
producción de las segundas dosis y
empezarán a entregar por otro lado en
argentina el laboratorio richmond que
fabrica a nivel local la vacuna informó
que en agosto prevé tener 3 millones de
dosis del segundo componente y por otro
lado las autor
edades sanitarias informaron que ya se
podrá empezar a combinar vacunas por un
lado para sputnik vez se podrá completar
el esquema con astrazéneca o modernas y
también en el caso de astrazéneca que es
otro otro caso en el que a veces están
faltando el segundo componente área no
en segundo componente sigo sino la
segunda dosis pues son dos dosis bueno
astrazéneca también podría completarse
con modernas ha llegado el caso porque
el objetivo dijo el ministerio de salud
en argentina es que en agosto este mes
se alcance un 60 por ciento de la
población mayor de 50 años con esquema
completo de vacunación
natalio muchas gracias por este completo
reporte desde la ciudad de buenos aires
en rápidamente vamos ahora con cifras de
vacunación como cierra esta semana la
inmunización mundial vamos a ver
porcentajes de población que han
recibido al menos una primera dosis de
algunas de las vacunas en el mundo
solamente el 29 punto 56 por ciento de
la población a nivel mundial tiene al
menos una dosis vamos de norte a sur
comenzamos por méxico
allí el 38 punto 24 por ciento de la
población ya tiene una dosis costa rica
el 50 puntos 51 por ciento un poco más
al sur colombia cierra esta semana con
37 puntos 0 1 por ciento de la población
con una primera dosis
bolivia allí la cifra llega al 25 05 por
ciento mientras que brasil llegó ya al
80 punto al 50 punto 80 por ciento de la
población
y al igual que en argentina también hay
preocupación en bolivia por el
incumplimiento de rusia a la hora de
hacer las entregas de sus lotes de dosis
de la vacuna sputnik ve muchos temen que
no alcanzaran a recibir la segunda dosis
de la vacuna de cara a la posible cuarta
ola de contagio que puede vivir el país
suramericano debido al avance de la
variante intenta
en realidad para el estudio y cuando el
gobierno anunció señora la llegada de la
columna
[Música]
ivette arellano de 57 años está entre
los 170 mil bolivianos que se han
quedado sin completar su esquema de
vacunación contra el cob y 19 porque
rusia ha incumplido con el envío de la
segunda dosis de la spu tikvá yo tengo
que hacer operar y por esta vacuna
esperan 90 días y ahora me encuentro en
una situación en un hilo colgando que no
sé a dónde me voy a dirigir el
presidente luisa se recibió la primera
dosis de la misma vacuna el 24 de mayo y
este mes debería tocarle la segunda ante
las críticas
minimizó el impacto de la falta de la
spot y que en el plan de vacunación sin
embargo de ello la expotec se presenta
sólo el 25 por ciento del stock de
vacunas que llegó a nuestro país el 75
por ciento es de otras vacunas y por lo
tanto están garantizadas
esta es la segunda vez que el instituto
estatal ruso gama ley a proveedor del
sputnik en cumple con el envío de la
segunda dosis de su vacuna el colegio
médico critica que se juegue con la
salud de la gente de gama ley en su
primera intervención decía 21 días y
había que colocar la segunda dosis para
potencializar luego solamente nos han
indicado de que había estudios para que
se coloquen 90 días y ahora se salen con
180 días y eso es algo que creo que no
se puede jugar con la salud
bolivia y rusia tienen varios proyectos
de desarrollo en común pero en el tema
de las vacunas la afinidad ideológica no
ha impedido los problemas en el
cumplimiento del contrato una falla que
ha dejado en la incertidumbre a miles de
personas sobre todo de la tercera edad
cuando se teme una eventual cuarta ola
del cód el 19
y ecuador de vacuno con al menos una
dosis para ser exactos al 53 punto 54%
de la población una cifra muy alentadora
para este país que comenzó un poco tarde
la vacunación y que ha sido una de las
grandes apuestas del gobierno de turno
allí en quito está nuestro
corresponsable gustavo ortega para
conocer más detalles gustavo ya lo
decíamos más del 50 por ciento de la
población con al menos una de las dosis
un aspecto muy positivo entonces para
las autoridades y pues ya aparece que
despegó la vacunación
hola qué tal de santiago el cuaderno
solo ya superó su meta de vacunar 9
millones de personas antes los primeros
100 días de gobierno una de las
principales ofertas de campaña del
actual presidente de guillermo lasso en
70 días aproximadamente se ha realizado
la cifra corresponde al 52 por ciento de
la población total del ecuador con la
primera dosis y el 70 por ciento de la
población de mayores de 16 años de edad
según datos oficiales del ministerio de
salud el programa de vacunación ha
mejorado luego que ecuador viviera su
peor crisis sanitaria empañada por caso
de corrupción el gobierno nacional
también anunció un nuevo plan para
reactivar la economía muy golpeada en
este país andino durante el mes de
agosto sólo se aplicarán segundas dosis
en las diferentes vacunas disponibles en
ecuador que hasta la fecha un poco más
de dos millones de personas fueron
inoculadas con las dos dosis el gobierno
se apoya la empresa privada para la
asignación de vacunas y aparecen en
facturas de pago en diferentes comercios
o puede consultarse vía telefónica un
sitio en internet y se realiza según la
edad durante toda la semana se hace de
manera más ordenada se utilizan centros
de vacunaciones colegios y algunos casos
en puntos de las donaciones precios para
vehículos y en centros como este donde
se realiza ya las personas no tienen que
hacer esas grandes colas que se veían
todos los días
gustavo hablando ahora de economía el
gobierno anunció nuevas medidas para
reactivar el turismo en este país como
un trampolín para impulsar la economía
ecuatoriana muy afectada por la pandemia
del cobi 19
si la reactivación económica es el
término que más se utiliza últimamente
en el país andino y para ello el
gobierno ha emitido cuatro medidas
relacionadas con el sector económico
turístico y tributario en este sentido
se anunció la eliminación del impuesto
de salida de divisas para la compra de
boletos aéreos una medida que busca
fortalecer el turismo mejorar la
conectividad internacional del país vía
aérea luego de la paralización de este
sector a causa de la pandemia
eliminación de las tarifas por
transferencias y pagos electrónicos es
otra medida anunciada para motivar así
el ahorro el ecuador impulsa el uso de
más medios electrónicos de pago y
disminuir el uso de dinero en efectivo
para evitar los contagios por contacto
con billetes y monedas según ha dicho
las autoridades del país también en ese
orden de ideas gustavo también están
pensando en seguir la idea que tiene
algunos países europeos como por ejemplo
francia de instaurar un pasaporte
sanitario para el movimiento ante
internos de los ciudadanos y también
para las personas que llegan
ecuatorianos que viven en el exterior
que más información hay al respecto
es correcto se aplicará un mecanismo
denominado pasaporte de vacunación la
iniciativa busca motivar que las
personas se vacunen y obtener beneficios
comerciales y descuentos en el consumo
quienes presenten un registro físico de
haber recibido las dos dosis en ciudades
como guayaquil el oro donde existe la
variante de altas se aplica mecanismo
para restringir el uso del transporte
público a quienes no cumplan con sus
dosis por ejemplo además se regalan
cajas de comida en algunas ciudades para
motivar la vacunación mientras que en
todo el país más de 667 categorías de
productos se pueden conseguir con
beneficios comerciales al presentar este
pasaporte de vacunación a partir de esta
semana ecuador busca activar su economía
reactivar la negociar acuerdos de libre
comercio y reactivar sectores turísticos
y ampliar la llegada con la aplicación
de nuevas dosis existentes en el país
pero no todas es vacunación ya que
también existen exigencias por parte de
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas que exigen al gobierno frenar
el alza del combustible eliminar el
sistema de bandas de precios y aplicar
en las tasas de interés específicamente
revisar los créditos y acuerdos de pago
que existe en el sector agrícola por el
cual también se espera una respuesta por
parte del presidente de la república
que no aceptará estas demandas por el
cual se para conocer cuál será la ruta
económica que seguirá el país andino en
los próximos años
gustavo pues estaremos muy atentos a las
novedades allí en ecuador' muchas
gracias por este completo reporte desde
la ciudad de quito ya ustedes pues
muchas gracias por la sintonía hasta
aquí
kobe 19 la semana en américa nos vemos
la próxima semana con otro resumen de
noticias de nuestro continente
relacionadas con la pandemia sigan
cuidando se sigan se lavando las manos y
usando el tapabocas nos vemos hasta la
próxima
[Música]